- Okay, but I become leader.
I had never heard
about this, right?
Because the FBI comes
and just provides it
to a select few people on Intel.
So I ask for a briefing.
Speaker Pelosi comes and
has this briefing with me.
What I know with
what the FBI told me,
he should never be on Intel,
and Pelosi reappointed
him in Intel.
I don't understand this.
- Have you said this to her?
- Yes.
- What did she say?
- But this is worse.
I brought a motion to the
floor to remove him from Intel,
put another Democrat on.
The Democrats all defended.
They don't even have the
briefing from the FBI,
but they defended having him on.
And think about this,
he cannot get a security
clearance in the private sector,
but they voted to let them
have the security clearance
of American secrets.
(gentle upbeat music)
- All right, I am live in studio
with congressmen and House
Minority Leader, Kevin McCarthy.
Good to see you, sir.
- Oh, good to be here.
Thanks for letting
me in the house.
- You came all the way
down from Bakersfield
to So Cal, LA.
How do you feel about
being in scary Los Angeles?
- Well, I represent a little
valley county in Lancaster,
but the temperature in
Bakersfield is pretty hot,
it's like 105 today.
So I thought it'd be
a little cooler here,
but it's not that much.
- Little cooler here.
When you come down to LA
and, look, it's Hollywood.
Did you make it
to Hollywood yet?
- I haven't made
it Hollywood yet.
- It's pretty messy.
The homeless situation,
the drugs, the crime,
the stores are all still closed,
half of the lockdown stuff.
What do you make of
what's happening?
I guess I'm talking
about So Cal first,
but just broadly in California.
- You know, the bad part
is everyone thinks, okay,
Southern Cal is so bad with
homeless, it's everywhere.
It's in Bakersfield.
It's in every single community.
But what I really was
shocked the other day,
when I came into
Southern California,
you've almost grown
accustomed to seeing homeless
under the overpasses, right?
- Yeah.
- And everywhere.
But they have
overtaken the beaches,
Little Shore Boulevard.
But what was shocking to me
is living on the freeway.
You know you have the banks,
they literally built
houses as you're driving.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
And, I mean, I'm shocked by it.
I'm thinking why and
how can this continue?
- So why is it?
Okay, so you're a congressmen,
it's happening in Bakersfield.
Why is it happening?
Is this all Newsom's fault?
Like what is really going on?
- Well, you know what?
- I came home.
It's not a federal issue,
but what the first
thing I did was
I brought a symposium
together, my mayor,
and I actually flew up Kevin
Faulconer out of San Diego.
He was the mayor of San Diego.
It was the only major
city in California
that actually decreased
homelessness, right?
So we got these
court cases out there
where you're not allowed to
pick a homeless person up
unless you have a
shelter for them.
But this is where the
cities go wrong, like LA.
They'll spend $500,000
on a little place
to put a homeless person.
They either majority
have a mental problem
or a drug problem.
And if you go back to where
Prop 47 was and others,
people used to be picked
up and put in local jails.
I just had my law
enforcement and the other day
we were talking
about this yesterday.
And what happens when they were
in there, they had programs.
They would dry up.
They would actually
make a decision.
Do they wanna get cleaned?
Do they wanna move forward?
But now they're not.
Now they're on the streets.
You can't pick them up.
You gotta give them
notice beforehand.
And you know what
was interesting
of why I brought Faulconer
up, he put three big tents up,
one, like all men,
one women with
children, and veterans.
And then he did a wraparound.
He put healthcare, he
put charter schools.
So maybe go to school
at two in the morning
if that's what's needed.
And he was able to pick
them up, move them,
give them the
healthcare they need
and others to be able to train.
These other cities don't
wanna lean into it.
In our community, we got
together and we would clean up,
we find other shelters for them,
but it's still
rampant throughout.
It is a challenging problem.
Part legal, part what
happened in Prop 47,
part what's happening now
on the treatment side.
And now we're finding people
that were getting treatment
they're not, and it's
a number of years.
So that drug element
has gone beyond that
to beyond mental
element as well.
And I think a lot
of it does come down
to Gavin as well,
though, for not tackling.
- So let's talk about Gavin.
You know I'm no fan of Gavin.
I've been screaming
about this recall.
You just mentioned
Kevin Faulconer.
There's a couple
of people running.
- There's four Kevin's running.
- Is there four Kevins?
- That's not even a big name.
- Wait, are you getting into it?
- No, but I just read
this today, four Kevins.
- Four Kevin's. All right.
Well look, is someone gonna win
because I think it was a win
to at least get the
recall to happen,
but it's not the win?
I mean, is there any chance
something happens here?
- There's a chance we win,
but this is what we
should all think about
across this country.
Remember what was happening
before the recall,
that these governors were
becoming so empowered,
that they could tell
us whatever we could.
They could tell us whether
we could go to church.
They could tell us
where we could eat.
I remember calling
Gavin's chief of staff,
where he had just put out
the restaurants could open
based upon square footage
who could be in there,
but a church can never
go more than 100.
So I talked to him,
well, how did you
determine the restaurant?
Well, by square footage.
Well, how did you
determine the church?
Well, not by square footage.
Where's the science?
But the only reason he
started lifting anything
is because of the recall.
- Yes.
- So what happened
was democracy at work?
It's the first time he
started waking up, right?
Tell us we couldn't do anything,
but he's at the
French Laundry, right?
All sitting together.
- You ever been
to French Laundry.
- No, I can't afford
it. (chuckles)
- You know, they spent
20 grand on the bar bill?
20 grand on the bar bill.
- Is that legal?
- And he was with a
bunch of lobbyists
he endorsed.
- He was with
the medical association.
- Yeah.
- It's a birthday party.
So what does California
need to really turn around,
whether it's the recall or
pushing Gavin to do some things
as the recall sort of has?
- We need leadership.
We need simple leadership.
And the challenge with
Gavin is that most people
that get into public service
have a philosophy and a
principle, and I admire that.
Even if the person has a
different principle philosophy
than I do.
'Cause you know where you could
find common ground, right?
No button, our
government's not designed
that one person gets
100% of what they want.
So how do I keep my principles,
how do I find common ground,
and how do you move
something forward?
Gavin will change
his opinion in a day,
and he does it by a poll.
What do I need to move here?
What do I need to go there?
Those are the people who
fail in this process.
And what I'm finding
in this, he needs,
here he is a Democrat governor
on the fifth largest
economy in the world
with Democrat
majorities on both sides
and he's afraid to lead, right?
Well, you lose all power
when you're not leading.
And think about
what the Democrats,
when they're looking for
the presidential future,
who's the leader of the
party, Gavin Newsom and Cuomo?
And what they did during COVID,
and we got DeSantis
and Kristi Noem.
They literally used
their principles,
not letting the federal
government tell them what to do.
I think the recall can pass
and I think it
would be eye-opening
for whoever could win the race.
And remember, now
that it's qualified,
what's the first thing
the Democrats did
Change the law.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Change the law but-
- Change the law.
Indeed they moved
it up also, right?
- Yeah, 'cause they
think it's an advantage
because now that Biden is in
and gave them
billions of dollars,
Gavin's gonna buy
his way out of it,
or try to at least, right?
So if you're low income and
you have a moving violation,
they'll pay for it, right?
Here they are with
everything hard about COVID,
they got $75 billion surplus?
I mean, it's crazy.
And then he held money
back from certain county.
But anyways, the last
recall was about Gray Davis.
And what happened
in that process,
people at the very beginning,
they would pull and say,
"I don't wanna
recall the governor,"
until they found out
who would replace him.
So I really think what
California is looking at,
to get to the recall,
it wasn't a bunch of
Republicans who signed it.
It was Independence,
it was Democrats.
And there was a
lot down here, why?
They're concerned
about homelessness,
but really affordability.
- They wanna go to work.
I went to a bunch
of their rallies.
These were not Republicans.
These were not conservatives.
These were people,
these were restaurant owners
who just wanted to go to work.
That's really what it was.
- They wanted to be
able to live their life.
I mean, who can't forget
that one young woman
who has that restaurant bar.
- Yeah.
- She was being shut down,
but the Hollywood
one gets to be open
right next door.
- I was there with her.
Yeah.
- So if you lay the rules out
and you abide by the rules,
you should be able
to carry forward,
but that doesn't play in
the Democrat, California.
They wanna change the
rules all the time.
So what I truly believe
if people are engaged,
we'll win this recall.
What has to happen when
you go to the vote,
you get two questions.
One, do you support the recall?
Yes or no.
And then you vote
for who to replace.
You need one person to
rise up to be the leader.
And it doesn't to be partisan.
I firmly believe
that will transfer
and make sure the recall passes.
- So who's that
person. (chuckles)
- Well, I don't know who
that person is just yet.
- You don't know who-
- And now we know the date.
- We know the date,
that's something.
What's it like for you as
a Republican Congressman
in this crazy state?
Just going around as a
conservative in blue California.
- You know what's Interesting,
if I'm on a plane and
I'm flying to Florida,
there's people who want
my autograph, applaud me.
In Texas, they'll cheer me.
- [Rubin] Yeah. Yeah.
- In California and New York,
they'll yell at me, right?
- Yeah.
- But that's okay. That's okay.
What's happening is
something I haven't seen
in quite some time.
Look, in California, we've
had Republicans and Democrats
who have managed this state.
And I firmly believe if we
could change the top two system.
I know why people want to
put in the top two system.
I never supported it.
But the top two
system takes us away
from having a
debate about ideas.
So what's happening
in the top two system
we're not getting the
very best people to run,
because think about this,
one of the most popular
governors in the country
is a guy named Baker
in Massachusetts.
He's a Republican.
Do you know there's not
one Republican Congressman
from Massachusetts?
It's overwhelmingly Democrat,
but they reelect this
governor, Maryland, right?
But what's happening
in California,
you're not getting the
quality people to run
because the top two people think
there's not enough Republicans.
But if we let the parties decide
on at least all the
constitutional offices,
we would have a debate of ideas.
And I truly believe
in California,
people would wanna
check and balance
that the legislature is so
far, it's not democratic.
It's socialist, right?
This wing has gone so far
that they would wanna
check and balance that.
If they got out of control,
they have somebody in
governor who'd veto the bill.
I think a Republican
could win governor
each and every
time in California.
I think an attorney general
Republican could win.
Target closes their
stores in San Francisco,
Neiman Marcus,
they just rent it.
- Yup.
- And why?
These are the
democratic policies
that have now been implemented
because they won the majorities,
now we're seeing the outcome.
That is why the
pendulum will swing.
- Why do you think Democrats
can't seem to associate
the people that they vote for
and the policies they vote for
for the bad stuff that happens?
Like all the people in
San Francisco right now
that are watching the
Neiman Marcus video
that we played it on the show
and just people running into
Walmart and into Walgreens.
I think 17 Walgreens closed
in the San Francisco area,
just stealing stuff.
And then you've got the
DA that won't prosecute.
And then now we've got the
former San Francisco DA
is now in Los Angeles.
I mean, you get, it's the swamp.
It's a mini swamp that we've
got here in California.
But for some reason, people
can't seem to realize,
oh, if you keep voting
in the same party
and things keep going wrong,
that there's maybe
a connection there
to the people you're voting in?
Is it the sun?
It's the weather, right?
It fries everybody.
(McCarthy laughs)
- I think it's a combination.
I don't think these
the Democrats of old.
When you study history in LA.
- I wrote the book.
- Yeah.
They weren't Democrats
who weren't crazy.
They were Democrats who
were conservative, right?
If you took Jerry
Brown's father,
if you compare Jerry Brown,
who I think is liberal,
compared to Gavin, he
seemed more conservative.
But what I found now
is they have shifted.
They have become a
socialist Marxist idea.
And that wing of the party
has become more powerful,
and the moderate wing
of the party is afraid
and they can't win anymore.
- Are you surprised how
quickly they folded?
That's one of the things
I'm just focused on
all the time, that they,
I don't think in his heart
of hearts that Chuck Schumer
is a true, like radical
leftist, or even Nancy Pelosi.
I don't really think that-
- He's afraid of him.
- Yeah. Maybe she is.
Yeah. Okay, okay.
- But Pelosi actually
gets dragged-
- I say that with
no love for her.
That was like trying to give
like a little bit of credit
that I don't think she's
like over the top AOC, but-
- You know what?
- They're afraid.
- No, she's jealous of AOC.
She believes she was
the founding liberal.
She's from San Francisco,
she's the founder,
and they, think of this,
AOC has more
followers than Pelosi.
When AOC got
elected to Congress.
remember, she won, I
get the number wrong.
She only won and
only had to have like
20,000 votes, right?
- No, its a tiny amount
of votes, yeah.
- But here she and
she has a name brand.
And she had more
followers than Pelosi.
She's giving Pelosi problems.
So what did the speaker
of the House do?
Had a meeting with her
and then took a picture.
- Yeah.
- You know who put
the picture out?
Not AOC, Pelosi,
because she believes
AOC is stronger.
And then look at this, in the
last election Pelosi saying
she's gonna win 15 seats.
She got the number
right, the party wrong.
It's the first time since
'94 no Republican lost,
and we beat 15 Democrats.
But the interesting part
is there is only one wing
of the Democratic
Party that grew.
Pelosi has a five-seat majority,
the smallest has
been in 100 years.
But the Cori Bush, the
AOC, the Talibs, the Omars.
That wing, the socialist wing
of the party, grew stronger.
They won and Pelosi lost.
- So how do you
take the House back?
- Oh, we take the House
back exactly what we did
in the last election, okay?
And you gotta analyze it.
In the last election,
had we not had COVID,
Trump would have won
re-election, okay?
Any historical factor
that you go through,
pandemics, the leaders
normally have a challenge.
The Senate, we really thought
Republicans would win,
and think about that.
You only needed one
seat to win in Georgia.
- Right. That's so-
- You had two, and you lost.
- Yeah.
- People could call a
malpractice on that, right?
- 'Cause think about
it, if you run-
- You trying to get me
booted from YouTube?
- No, no, no.
But if you run as a
Republican in Georgia,
you start with a
four-point advantage.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Okay?
In the House, everyone
believed we'd lose 15 seats.
Even our own pollsters
that we'd lose.
But think about this, we went
2010, we beat 63 Democrats.
Not every incumbent wins.
So in this last election
with all the wind against us,
every single incumbent wins,
but we beat 15 Democrats.
Every Democrat lost
to a Republican woman
or a Republican minority.
We elected more Republican women
than any time in the
history of the part, okay?
So now only two times in
the history of the country
has the party in power,
meaning whoever controlled
the White House,
lose the White House and
gained seats in the house.
1892 in 1992,
and both times they won the
majority two years later, okay?
31,731 votes.
That's how short we came up
from winning the majority,
out of more than 152 million.
So what really happened there
was about four or five seats.
I didn't have enough
money, we didn't plan.
And we lost by less
than two points.
People didn't quite
see what was happening
at the silent majority.
That's why, when you talk about,
can we win the
recall in California?
Yes, I don't care what the
pollsters say because momentum.
The next election is
gonna be big, right?
'Cause all of these things
about defunding the police,
all these Democrat policies
that are now going in place,
we're seeing the
outcome, the woke-ism,
the open border, the inflation.
Where we're gonna have the
biggest victory, school boards.
We hadn't been paying attention
for the last 20 years.
Critical race
theory goes against
everything Martin Luther
King has ever told us.
Don't judge us by the
color of our skin,
and now they're
embracing it, right?
They're going backwards.
And the interesting
part here is, okay,
something else is happening,
not just an election,
and it'll be a national
election for Congress.
What history says is
the party in power,
whoever wins the White House
on the first off year election
loses 27 seats.
We lost 40, Obama lost 63.
And they have a
five seat advantage.
In the last election cycle, we
targeted about 50 Democrats.
Only one retired, okay?
This cycle already five
Democrats have retired,
and I'll bet you
that gets over 10.
And why they're retiring
is because you have
redistricting as well, right?
Redistricting doesn't
affect the Senate,
but it does the House.
Almost every seat,
unless you go statewide.
And what redistricting tells
us is people move, right?
So we've got this
amazing ability,
the states and the
10th amendment, right?
They're like pilot projects.
They're like startups, right?
I mean, welfare reform didn't
start in Washington, DC,
it started in Wisconsin.
Some of our best ideas are
driven from the bottom up,
not from the top down,
and the Democrats love
the top down, okay?
So for the first time in
the history of the state,
California is not gaining,
we're losing a seat.
New York, Illinois, who gains?
Florida, Texas, right?
So what's gonna happen here,
people are moving based
upon the philosophy.
I believe it's gonna
be an interesting time
because here the Democrats
are gonna be sitting back.
They realize they're in trouble.
They've been in office
for a little while.
Do they wanna go have
to meet new constituents
and explain to them
why they defend
the message of Maxine waters?
Or why they aren't standing
up to protect our borders?
Or what are they doing
economically, but
creating inflation?
Why are they paying people
more money to stay home
and instead they
go back to work?
Why are they making
our military woke?
I think that silent
majority is gonna wake up
and I think there's gonna
be a pretty big swing.
So the number one
thing you have to have
is the quality of the candidate.
- So what does the sort of
next wave of Republicans
look like to you?
I mean, there is sort
of this battle now.
Is it gonna be
like the Trump wing
or is it gonna be the more
old school Republican wing?
Is there some brand of that?
Where does Trump fit into this?
- Well look, this is
the way I look at.
It's interesting
within Trump, right?
'Cause Trump did a couple
of different things.
He expanded the party, okay?
So when people sit
back and think,
oh, I bet Trump really
hurts you in the campaign.
No, he didn't hurt us.
Do you know what the best
state for Republicans were
in the last election?
- Statewide?
But if you're gonna
tell me it's California,
my head's gonna explode.
- It's California.
- Because what?
- Just in terms of-
- We gained four seats.
- Yeah.
- But put it in perspective.
Trump lost California
by 5 million votes.
- Right. Right.
He didn't compete here.
The four seats of the
Democrats we beat,
Trump lost all four, three
of them by double digits.
So they go into the polls.
By more than 10 points,
they vote for Biden,
but by the 10 points they
reject the incumbent.
- Is that shocking to you?
I mean, that's gotta be
close to unprecedented.
That sort of disconnect
between the top of the ticket.
- It's the quality
of the candidate.
Did you realize we won
two seats in Miami?
And this is a part you
should really look at.
Do you realize that the
biggest border district
in the country goes from
El Paso to San Antonio?
A guy by the name of
Tony Gonzales ran,
never been elected before.
Trump endorses him and he wins
the primary by seven votes,
but he wins, it's a
70% Hispanic seat.
He wins the seat.
It wasn't even on
people's radars
'cause they didn't
think we had a chance
by a bigger margin
than will hurt anyone.
Okay.
In Miami, Maria
Salazar, Carlos Mendez,
these are Democrat seats,
but you know why we won?
'Cause the population
in those districts
are made up of Cubans
and Venezuelans,
who understand freedom.
- They get it, they get it.
- They don't just get it, they
left what they see happening
on the Democratic side.
So we grew in areas people
haven't thought before.
Now, the question was about
what's the future look like.
If you look at Trump's policies,
the majority of Americans
would agree with him.
Personality is what
got people at times
to disagree with Trump.
So if you separate
personality from the policies
and here we are going
into an election
where contrast make
elections happen, right?
So here we have policies
that we know we had,
low unemployment,
everybody had a job,
we looked strong
around the world,
we're energy independent,
we had a secure border.
Within six months
what have you done?
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- I believe when that debate
is gonna be about policy,
we're gonna win big.
- All right, so let's shift
from the everyday
machinations of politics
and talk about the
other big stuff
that I know has
been on your mind,
it's on my mind all the time.
Let's talk about
the big tech stuff.
We got some problems with big
tech and I know you're trying
to figure out-
- That's the thing
that can stop us from winning.
- Yeah, so let's
talk about that.
Well, first off, I guess,
how manipulated do you
think we are first?
Like just generally by big tech,
like just the way
that we're able
to talk to each other
and communicate.
- More than we ever imagine.
More than we even think about.
Okay, you and I should
have a discussion.
Let's discuss your book.
Don't burn this book.
And when this interview is over,
I'm gonna turn on my phone,
I bet you I get an
advertisement for it.
- I'm okay with that.
(McCarthy laughs)
That one I'm okay with.
- But do we think Siri
only listens to us
when We talk to him?
But what's even more important,
it's almost every aspect
of our lives, right?
But it's gathering what
information we can know
and what we can think,
and what we can see.
But it's also driving
us to dislike people
even if they think
differently than we do.
And you know, they'll tell
you, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's an algorithm."
Who writes the algorithm?
In 2018, right
before the election,
if you Googled the
California Republican party,
you know what they'd tell
you, our ideology was?
Nazi-ism.
How was that even in play?
Google and-
- Are you saying it
doesn't say it anymore?
I'd be shocked if
they came around.
- Well, they probably
brought it back up today.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But what's happening
here from the aspect of 90%
of everybody that
searches goes on Google.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- If you're on the second
page, 90% drop off.
So they control whether you
make it or break it, right?
But they also, if we are
a young company moving up,
they are so big.
They take your
technology, they buy you,
or they crush you, right?
So you don't have that
free market system.
When you sit back and think
who should have been Amazon?
Sears and Roebuck, right?
They have the catalogs,
they sold you from a house
to a pair of jeans, to tools.
They have the resource,
but Amazon came in a time
where there was a free market.
They started selling
books, they started.
But now Amazon is
just not Amazon.
Amazon hosts everybody.
So if they wanna take you
off you now can't be there.
If Apple doesn't want to put
you into the app who finds you?
- Yep.
- They control so much
of our life.
Think about it, if I grabbed
your phone, you'd fight me.
- Yeah, (chuckles)
- If you take your
kid's phone away,
it's the worst thing that
could happen to them.
- Yeah.
- It's almost a drug to us now,
but it controls so much what
we can see, what we can know,
what we can hear.
And if they disagree with
you, they can take you off.
If they don't like
your competition, they
can take you away.
That's the problem.
- So what do you
see is the answer?
Is this, we go in and
we have regulators
look at the algorithm.
I always have this running
joke that you're gonna have
some middle management
bureaucrat going to Google,
like, let me see the algorithm.
Or are we breaking them up?
I mean, where does
competition fit in?
Like, what's the-
- This is the way I put,
the first approach
we should take is,
everybody should realize
if something's on the
internet that's free,
you're the product.
- Yeah.
- Okay?
So if you're the product,
we should think of ourselves
as private property, right?
So if I'm the product and
we're private property,
what goes on your site,
if you're monetizing it,
I get a piece of it.
And I get to know
what you're doing
with my information, right?
It's not like this form
that attorney has to read.
Everyone just clicks yes or no.
Let's set of foundation
of what the priorities
of these forms should be
so they're clear
spoken that people know
what they're getting.
If you're monetizing,
I get a piece of it.
If I wanna get off your
site, I get my data back.
If I wanna move my data,
I can move my data.
I think that's a fairness
that everybody starts with.
The other thing that has
to happen here is though,
we've got to make sure
there's a level playing field
where there's competition.
And I don't think big
government creating utilities.
Is there competition
for PG and E?
No.
They just raise our rates,
and they give us brown outs,
and we pay 40% higher
than anybody else?
I want somebody to
come in and disrupt.
I want the next one, right?
We had Microsoft
before we had Google.
And the other challenge is,
if somebody wants
to go to the court,
it takes too long, right?
So I understand at the beginning
why we gave you
Section 230, right?
You wanted the
platform to begin.
I will keep 230 in
only this perspective,
if you let people say on the
platform, what do they want?
'Cause it's liability protection
for you to allow the
people to do that.
- But is it too late.
I've had this conversation
with other congresspeople,
and plenty of pundits,
and everything else.
It's like, well, why
didn't anything happen then
when they dragged Zuckerberg?
In front of Congress,
they dragged Zuck.
- Because Section 230
is still there.
So if you remove Section 230,
now the platform has
a question to make.
If I wanna regulate
what's on there,
a person has a right
to go to court.
If we go to court one time,
do a big class action,
I'll guarantee you they'll
change their behavior.
Structure, dictates behavior.
Right now we're protected.
- Isn't that what Trump
is now announcing?
He's doing just in the
last couple of days.
So he's gonna do it-
- But think about
it for one moment.
Regardless of how anyone
feels about Trump.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- He had the most
people on Facebook,
probably the most
followers on Twitter.
He was the president
of the United States.
Our very first amendment
is freedom of speech,
and they took them off.
And the place I heard
the most complaints from
was Merkel in Germany.
I mean, think about it.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- 32 years ago, a
million college kids
went to Tiananmen Square for
the idea of freedom of speech.
The 3 million people out
of 8 million in Hong Kong
that would go out in the rain
craved freedom of speech,
and we had just allowed that
to be denied to an American.
And then once they
did it to him,
they did it to everybody else
that they disagreed with.
Why have we come so far that
you and I could sit down,
you could have a total
different philosophy?
We could debate, but we don't
have to dislike each other.
When we take away the debate,
we're taking away a
foundation of who we are.
I mean, I should not be afraid
that someone has a
different belief than I
and debate the idea.
It either makes my ideas
stronger, makes me believe more.
I mean, I'm a Republican, but
my family are all Democrats.
I chose to be in this party.
So when someone
wants to challenge me
on my conservative beliefs,
I wasn't born here,
I chose to come here.
I think I'm gonna have
a stronger belief.
I rejected what
somebody said at home
and was seeking
out something else.
- Wait, let's stick
with that for a moment,
because I think you know a
little bit about my story.
- Yeah.
- I was a big Lefty.
So I'm curious, I didn't
know that about you.
So you come from a
family of Democrats.
- We were all Dems, I was the
first Republican in my family.
- What was your moment?
- So I'm older than you.
- We'll get back to-
- I'm 56.
- Yeah.
- Reagan was the first
president I could vote for.
It was in the second term.
But when I was in elementary
school, I watched junior high,
Jimmy Carter, go on
TV, put a sweater on,
tell me to turn the heater down
and told me the best days
of America were behind us.
- Yeah.
- He accept mediocracy.
And I watch this other guy
go to a podium and says,
"No pastels.
Fly the bold colors and go to
that shiny city on the hill."
I knew what he meant, right?
That America is
exceptional, right?
If you come to my office,
I want you to come
to DC sometimes.
- [Rubin] Yeah. Yeah.
- So I have this portrait
of Reagan behind me,
it's in color, right?
And I have this other
portrait that's very big
and it's Lincoln.
And it's in black and white,
The greatest challenge
ever to our constitution
was the Civil War.
And at night, if you sat
back in what's happening
and you ask these two people
to give us advice today,
Lincoln would say,
believe in the
exceptionalism of America.
And this is what makes me mad
coming off the 4th of July.
Why would we celebrate
the progress?
We're not perfect, but as we
strive from a perfect union,
Lincoln said,
"Conceived in Liberty
and dedicate the proposition
that we're all equal."
He goes on to say, "But if we
fail government of the people,
by the people, for the people
shall not perish from earth."
We weren't the world power,
but he understood the strength
of what a democracy and
a republic were, right?
There is no other nation in
the world conceived in Liberty
and dedicated they're all equal.
Maybe Israel, but
no other one, right?
Lincoln would also
tell us this, right?
"As an elected official,
don't be afraid of making
a tough decision," right?
The whole debate of slavery
didn't start in 1850.
It was the creation
of our country,
but they thought it was too
divided, to divisional, right?
That it would divide
us, divide the colonies.
So they said to put it aside,
and doing so, hundreds
of thousands of
their children died.
We don't have a decision
like that today,
but our debt, our challenge
with China, right?
Are we too afraid
as elected official
to make a decision
that we can lose upon?
But what happens
is you narrow it,
you're eventually
gonna make decisions,
but you're gonna
have fewer options.
And the other thing Lincoln
would tell us today is,
don't blame other people
for your problems.
Think about it, he gets
elected November, 1860,
but not sworn until March, 1861.
Never once did he
blamed Buchanan.
He understood where he was.
What was it, seven
states left the union
in that short amount of time?
Now, Reagan, I
have him in color.
And this is something for you,
this is something for
every conservative.
This is what he'd be,
and he'd even say it
to liberals, right?
If you believe in
your philosophy,
if you truly believe your
philosophy and principles
bring people more freedom,
don't be angry, be happy.
I get upset that these people
say I'm more conservative
'cause I'm angry.
All that means is less people
wanna have dinner with you.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Reagan brought
Democrats in, right?
People wanna know
what he was drinking.
Why was he so happy?
He had the 11th commandment.
He didn't tear another
Republican down.
He brought humor to it,
but he knew-
- He was basically
in the "Rat Pack."
The guy was cool.
I just watched the
"Rat Pack" documentary.
He's like, he's hanging
out with Sinatra.
Like, yeah.
- You want it to be around.
- Yeah.
- The other thing
Reagan would tell us,
and this would be critical
for the time and nature
of who we are, peace without
freedom is meaningless.
Think about that.
Peace without freedom
is meaningless.
It is human nature
that we crave peace,
but we cannot attain it
without having freedom, okay?
So, so many times in history
we watched if people
has failed, right?
Chamberlain, peace for our time.
What'd he do?
He claimed he created
peace by appeasing Hitler,
by giving him a country.
All Hitler understood,
your weakness
and I'm gonna beat you, right?
Barack Obama,
concerned about Iran.
He gave them billions of
dollars thinking they would,
and then said, "You can
have a nuclear weapon.
You just have to wait 10 years."
There was no freedom in
that, so there was no peace.
So they took that money
and they funded terrorism
around the Gulf.
Reagan had the same dilemma.
He's in his second term.
He's sitting next to Gorbachev,
he's in Iceland, right?
He's actually having
no staff in the room
and he's negotiating
a nuclear reduction.
He's getting almost
everything he asked for,
but Gorbachev
asked him for this.
Gorbachev asked him to
end the SDI program.
But remember the time and
place when Gorbachev has him.
It was a joke, right?
People called it "Star Wars."
It is the Iron Dome today
that shoots missiles down.
It's what protects us.
Reagan, you know what he does?
He doesn't say, "Let
me talk to Congress."
He says, "No, but I'll
do something else.
I'll share it with you so
the world will be safe."
Gorbachev declines.
So Reagan has, here's a document
that he got a lot of
what he was asking for,
but it didn't do anything
for those in the gulags.
It didn't do anything
for (indistinct)
So he realized there
was no freedom in it,
so there would be no peace.
So he got up and he walked away.
And there's this famous picture
of him like in a raincoat,
going out rejected.
- [Rubin] Yeah. Yeah.
- Every media, elite media,
criticized him, right?
But had not walked
away at that moment,
the Berlin Wall would
not have collapsed,
the Soviet Union would
not have collapsed.
And what's interesting
to me in modern time,
there've been two presidents
that've gotten the
Nobel Peace Prize,
Jimmy Carter and Barack Obama.
The two presidents who
deserved it really,
were Ronald Reagan
and Donald Trump.
What he did in the Abraham
Accords were amazing.
But-
- I thought we're not allowed
to call them that
anymore, right?
Isn't that what the
administration says?
They're the Middle East
peace, not really thing
or something like that.
- Well, they're trying
to tear them down.
- Yeah.
- But this is the challenge.
When you think about that,
what drove me to this party.
And I love...
We had a debate the
other day on the floor
to remove statues, right?
Every state gets
us into statues.
So the Democrats had a bill
to remove these statutes
as these were
Confederate individuals.
So I go to the floor.
I voted for the bill.
I voted for it last time.
And so let me just
get this straight.
You wanna remove
Democrat statues
that were sent to us by states
that were controlled
by Democrats years ago,
and sent to Congress that
had a Democrat majority
that accepted them.
Well, I just didn't think
that bill went far enough?
Why didn't they
change their name?
Do you realize.
- Is that where this all ends?
It ends with the
Democratic Party
basically having to
commit Harry Carey
because it was pretty much
them that did all this.
- Who's the first
Republican president?
- Abraham Lincoln.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
'Cause he left.
He didn't wanna be
pulled out the wigs
and then they brought the
non slavery Democrats.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And then what happened?
Have you ever thought from,
and if you're gonna
write another book,
we should collaborate on this.
- Yeah.
- What would America look like
had Lincoln not
been assassinated?
Malice towards none.
Would we ever had Jim Crow laws?
Do you know how
Jim Crow laws came
and who authored Jim Crow laws?
The Democrats.
- Yeah.
- How did they do it?
Because after the Civil War,
the south was controlled
by Republicans,
white Republicans and
black Republicans.
And who'd they elect,
Who's the first black
American elected to Congress.
It's a portrait in my
offices too, Joseph Rainey.
Where was he elected from?
Charleston, South Carolina.
If you study American history,
the Civil War
started there, right?
He was a slave.
He was elected in 1870.
Do you know when the first
black Democrat was elected?
60 years later.
But what happened there
got up to 23 black
Republicans elected.
So we had a race for the
presidency that was close.
So the Democrats cut a
deal with the Republicans,
that will go with you that
you won if you do one thing,
if you remove the federal
troops from the south.
So they removed the federal
You know what happened?
They intimidated now black
Americans from voting,
who happened to be Republicans.
And the Democrats took
over the state houses
in the Southern states.
And that's where Jim
Crow laws were created
based upon Joseph Rainey.
Now you wanna know
a modern history?
Who's the only black American
to get elected to the House,
and to the Senate?
- House and Senate.
- Tim Scott.
- Okay.
- And do you know
where he got elected
to the house?
- Well, I'm assuming-
- Charleston, South Carolina.
- Okay. Yeah.
(Rubin chuckles)
- Isn't that something.
- But then they criticize him.
Remember when he got
up and gave a speech?
- Oh yeah. It was extraordinary.
- Why wouldn't you celebrate
regardless of a person's
color of skin their success?
- So what do you do with that?
So Tim Scott gives the speech
after the State of the Union,
and in effect, everyone's
calling him a self-hating black.
It's all the worse stuff.
- Washington Post
wanted to go after him.
- Yeah.
- If you know anything
about Tim Scott,
it's Tim Scott's mother
is a Saint, right?
She's an amazing woman.
Tim Scott and his brother.
His mom gets divorced, right?
So they spend a lot of
time with the grandparents.
Every day they had
to eat breakfast
and his grandfather
had the newspaper out.
And for years Tim Scott
thought his grandfather
was reading the newspaper.
It wasn't until later
in life that he find out
his grandfather could not read.
But what his
grandfather was doing
was instilling in his grandsons
that you cared about
current events,
you cared about
what was going on.
Tim Scott family
had to pick cotton.
They had every reason to hate
America, but they did not.
Martin Luther King had
reasons to hate America,
but he did not.
Strive to be that
more perfect union.
So as we hear people
wanna talk about
what's negative about us,
why don't we highlight
what's right about?
Why don't we strive to be
that more perfect union?
Why do we tear
somebody else down?
You can have a different
opinion than I,
but the great thing
about America,
you have a right to say it.
- So it seems is
fairly obvious to me,
and I think probably
most of my audience
that most conservatives,
let's say,
or Blue Dog Democrats,
basically everyone non-woke
agrees with what
you just said there.
We can agree to disagree.
All right, you want this tax
rate, I want this tax rate.
Even on abortion.
In my book, I make a
begrudging pro-choice argument.
Most of my audience
is conservative now.
And you know what most
people said to me,
"Dave, I disagree with you
on that, but it's all good."
Or they usually say, "You'll
come around to my opinion
soon enough," but they
don't hate me for it.
So the point is
that on the right,
there is plurality of
opinion, but what do you do?
I mean this for you personally,
but also professionally
in what you do,
what do you do with
a group of people?
AOC is not here to negotiate
with you, obviously.
Ilhan Omar is not here
to negotiate with you
or negotiate what America is.
So what do you do with that?
- You know what's
sad though too.
Look, I respect them.
Getting elected to
Congress is not easy.
Think of Congresswoman
Omar's life, right?
Born in Somalia.
It's not an easy life.
Lives in a refugee camp.
But what does America do?
She does what she does,
some of our greatness.
She opens up her arms, she
brings her in her family,
and she becomes a citizen
of America, right?
And the moment she raised
her hand, became a citizen,
the flag that flies on
the moon was her flag.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Abraham Lincoln
was her liberator,
Martin Luther King spoke
of her dreams, right?
She has as much
right as you and I,
but she has as much
responsibility.
But what strikes me to be odd,
why does she have
such negative things
to say about the country
that embraced her?
That gave her...
Think about this,
less than 13,000 people have
ever had the opportunity
to be a member of Congress.
Not only did America
bring her in, she serves.
She decides the future
of this country.
When you think, my God, this
is the greatest thing on earth.
- So what do you do with that?
I mean, as a member of Congress,
what do you do when you
look across the aisle,
and to me, maybe I can say
what you can't quite say,
I think they're here
to burn it down.
I think the simple answer
to what you're saying is,
they don't want the America
that you were talking about
in the history,
but they don't want the history
you're talking about to.
Taught. We know that.
- They don't want the history.
If they wanna change the names,
if they want look at-
- CRT, the whole thing.
I think everyone gets it.
So then what do
you do with that?
This is not the Democrat that
you were across the aisle
up to 20 years ago.
- Division divides this nation
and a house divided
cannot stand in
and that still stands today.
We cannot allow it to happen.
I can respect you,
but you cannot let
them divide the people.
And this is what's happening
on college campuses, right?
I got a question from some
interns the other day,
what should I do?
Even if you disagree
with that person's,
what they're saying, you
should stand up for them.
Don't let people be bullied.
Don't let people try to
you have to have one thing.
But this is what's happening,
and it's happening to our
schools for quite some time
and now we're waking up.
It's now happening
when it comes to media,
when it comes to companies.
They intimidate you, right?
You can't get political,
you can't have a political pack
because you can't give to
somebody in the process.
We're gonna boycott you
if you don't boycott
the baseball game,
when you don't even
know the facts, right?
This is what has gotten
so far and so wrong
that these people,
and now that we're trying to
make woke into our military.
I mean, we should respect people
and the rule of law
should live the day.
That's one of the things
that makes us strong, right?
Eventually even OJ
gets convicted, right?
This is a challenge here that
what they're trying to do
to the nation.
And study modern history.
Think about what
happened in Venezuela.
Venezuela was a
democratic country.
It was the jewel
of Latin America.
Oil was at $100.
Hugo Chavez got elected, not
because he had a revolution.
He got elected in a democracy.
And then we got elected,
what did he do first?
He started saying,
"You know what?
We should have free school.
We should have free healthcare."
And it costs a lot of money.
So you know what?
Government is more efficient.
In his view, we should
take over those companies.
And you know what?
The Supreme Court said,
no, that that's not legal.
You know, I should
pack the courts.
When they didn't let that,
now I'm gonna change
the constitution,
get rid of the entire Congress.
And lo and behold, now
I have a dictatorship.
And why does everybody
leave your country?
Because the outcome.
Just like the same ideas,
why you wanna defund the police
in what's Minneapolis
wanna do today.
They wanna put
more money into it.
But it's worse than
that because now
people don't wanna be officers.
- Right, they're all retiring
and they don't wanna be-
- You can't bring it back on.
- Yeah.
- And then the outcome
of what you get,
people shouldn't
have to serve time,
so we just let people out.
Then we got
homelessness everywhere.
So you're not getting treatment.
- So are we at sort of an
intractable place then?
I mean, one of the things
I've been thinking about
is that maybe we really,
I don't want the country
to break up, obviously,
but maybe that we really
do need parallel economy,
sorta linking this back
to the big tech argument,
and that there
will be woke things
and then there will
be the rest of us.
And we will build our things
and they will
build their things.
And I don't know where
the political piece
of that fits totally.
- Listen, government
is not designed
where somebody gets
100% of what they want.
You've gotta find common ground.
What sets it apart from
every other country?
You go to France,
you become a citizen,
you're not French.
We're the only country
that you assimilate
and you become one,
and that's some of our
greatest strength, right?
And you're equal.
It doesn't matter if you're
a man, woman gay, straight.
Whatever you are,
you're equal here.
That sets us apart
from every other nation
'cause they're not like this.
You can't let them divide us.
It will harm us in the
long run if we're divided.
Now, can we have
differences of opinion
and respect one another?
Yes, you can.
But the idea of trying
to divide people
is gonna break us.
And I've watched that,
where there's the intimidation
of make it happen,
to try to make that happen.
And that's where
leadership comes in.
Remember what Winston Churchill
said it's about, it's right?
You could always count on
Americans to do what's right
after they exhausted
every other option.
Well, we always think it's
the worst of times, right?
No.
In the '60s, they killed
JFK, they killed Bobby,
they killed Martin Luther King.
There were riots
all in the streets.
We were much more divided then.
We know the right thing to do.
What's happening is the
division is creating people
to dislike people more,
to attack somebody based
upon their beliefs.
People come to your houses.
People intimidate
you for nothing.
That is what we should
all stand up against.
- So is that just because it's
fueled by social media now?
'Cause if you think
back to the '60s,
it was incredibly
divided, as you said.
There were at least three
massive assassinations.
Fortunately, we
don't have that now,
but within two years,
basically, or three years,
that mean three
assassinations like that.
So is that, to link this
back to the big tech part,
is that because this is
all fueled by information.
that's just traveling and-
- I think a combination.
So you've got big tech
and at the same time
you now, where do you
go to get your news?
You don't get your
news, you get opinion.
- I go to Twitter. (chuckles)
- Yeah. Okay.
But if you go to watch
television tonight,
you can watch a station
that philosophically
agrees with you.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- That's gonna give you opinion.
- Are they gonna tell
you the positive things
or they gonna rile you up?
Then you're gonna go to Twitter,
and people are,
it's human nature
that you could attack
somebody you don't know,
and you can repeat
something that's not true,
and you can mobilize
something like that, right?
That's what other
countries do to us.
They try to divide us
within their ranks.
What was the Soviet
union's idea?
To destroy America with no
shot being fired, right?
- [Rubin] Do a Twitter bots.
- Yeah, this is what
technology has done to us.
But what's happened is,
if you look at the four
biggest technology, right?
If you look at Facebook,
Google, YouTube, Instagram,
well, they're not four,
they're two, right?
So they can control what's
thought, what's said,
what's motivated,
what's popular.
How to move something
at a given time.
That becomes a problem.
What do we value, right?
Do you value fame or you
value the ability of success?
Anyone who has a job has
worth, has a sense of worth.
And what's big government done.
Tell you, "No, no, no.
You don't need to work.
No, no, we'll pay
you to not do that."
It takes a sense of
worth away from you.
And then someone goes
and puts all their
risk into something.
I started my first business
when I was 20 years old.
(indistinct), right?
So I actually won the
lottery in California
on the second day.
It was before lottery.
I was flipping cars to pay
my way through college.
I was gonna go to San Diego
state to visit some friends
at college, right?
So I go to the local grocery
store to cash a check,
you can tell how wealthy I am.
So I'm sitting in line, the
lottery started the day before.
So I'm buying a ticket-
- Oh, you mean this literally.
I thought-
- No, this is is a true story.
- (chuckles) The reason
I won the lottery,
like I lived in California.
I was young. Okay.
- So I tell my buddy.
- Yeah.
- I said, I'm
gonna say if I win,
I'll give you a hundred bucks.
I buy a ticket, I
scratch it off, I win.
The most you can win is $5,000.
Put your self in
my position, right?
You're 20 years old, it's
1985, it's Friday night,
you just won $5,000,
and you ended up 10 minutes
from Tijuana, right?
Okay.
- Oh-oh.
- So I come back, I
take my folks at dinner.
My brother orders, dessert
to make the price higher.
They give him-
- At the time,
did they cash it
out right there?
- I took it to the lottery store
and then they sent me a check,
like a week or two later, right?
5,000 bucks, the
full amount, right?
So then I went, I took
the kind of the majority
the rest of the money I have,
I put it all in one stock
'cause I wanna take a risk.
I made about 30% of my
money in six weeks, okay?
So I wanna buy a franchise,
but no one will sell me one
'cause I'm 20 years old.
So I go and I open this deli.
I even built a counter
in my dad's garage.
And there's three lessons I
learned from my small business.
I was the first to work,
I was the last to leave,
I was last to be paid.
But you know what?
Pretty successful.
About a year and
a half afterwards,
I now have enough capital
that could pay my whole
way through college.
as long as I go to
Cal State, right?
- [Rubin] Wow.
- No one in my family had
finished four-year degree.
So I sell my business.
Gone to school,
open up the paper,
says be a summer intern
in Washington, DC
with my local congressman.
Don't know him, but think
he'd be lucky to have me.
I apply, and you
know what he did?
He turned me down.
You wanna know the
end of the story?
I now sit in the
congressional seat
I couldn't get an
internship for.
- Wow.
- Only in America
could that happen?
- Yeah.
- Right?
So how could it
happen again today
if government will pay you more,
instead of go work for the
small business starting out,
or if you took all that
risk and opened it up
and they put you under?
- Is that what this really-
- They're picking
winners and losers.
- So is that what this
really is all about?
Like this whole conversation,
almost everything
wrong with the country.
'Cause I'm hearing you say that,
and it's like, man, that's
what America is about.
That's what life is
about, purpose, and risk,
and all of those things.
And now we have a government.
- We're taking it all away.
- Just this morning,
right before you walk in,
I saw this tweet by
Biden and it was like,
we're gonna expand child
healthcare from the state
and we're gonna expand
two-year college.
And it's exactly what you're
saying about Venezuela.
Like, where would you,
if you ever wanted to
brainwash your generation,
wouldn't you just keep
sending them to state schools
and say be more and
more reliant on us?
I mean, to me, this is
what it's all about.
More than big tech part in
a way and everything else.
Just the expansion of,
we'll do everything for you.
- You know what's great?
Is Richard Branson is gonna
go to space privately.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Americans take risk.
That's what sets us apart
because we accept risk.
Do we want more attorneys
or more engineers, right?
An attorney wants
to eliminate risks
that have you do nothing, right?
They want government to
do everything for you.
Everybody has an opportunity.
We wannaúgive them all
an opportunity to start.
But what you do once you're 18,
the outcome's not
gonna be the same.
But the Democrats believe
everybody's outcome
is gonna be the same.
No. That doesn't work.
I want you to be
successful as you can,
but I want you to
have the same ability
to be able to be successful,
to be able to take the risk.
And if I take the
risk and I get reward,
I don't want the
government taking it all.
- But are you shocked
that they've moved
on this equity thing
instead of equality?
That now that it's
it's about the result,
not, you know, the end spot
instead of all the years
of work to get there?
- So, we don't have what is
called the State of the Union
in their first term.
It was a joint joint
chambers we had
and we had the president come.
And so go back and you-
- I like that.
You're doing a 10-minute
correction on me there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Rubin laughs)
- That was very subtle
what you did there.
It wasn't a State of Union.
So it was joint
session of Congress,
but in the first year,
it's technically not-
- Yeah, it's not
a State of Union
because they just came in, yeah.
- That was interesting.
You didn't call
me out originally,
then you slid it in there.
Very impressive. Very.
- But it actually (indistinct).
So as a leader, I'm part
of an escort committee.
So you go back and you
greet the president,
who's the president at the time.
And so at this time
we're coming out,
we've got our mask on, right?
And then there's Bernie Sanders.
And I disagree with Bernie,
but I respect Bernie.
He believes what
he believes, right?
He doesn't back away from it.
He's not gonna go
down in history
as passing any legislation,
but he's a movement
politician, right?
I see Bernie against the wall.
I just talked to President
Biden and I come out.
I say to Bernie,
think about this.
Bernie is the chair of the
Senate Budget Committee.
He's a socialist, but he's
chair of Senate Budget.
But he never backed away.
He ran as a socialist, right?
- Yeah.
- So I said to him,
did you ever think
you'd be more conservative
than the president
of the United States?
And he kinda looks at me
kinda laughs, but it's true.
All that stuff you
just brought up,
Biden has moved-
- Right, Biden is doing it.
- Yes.
Biden literally, and
I believe most people
who become president
try to model themselves
after a former president.
Biden's trying to model
himself after FDR.
And think about all that stuff,
the challenge of what
FDR did in that place.
He packed the courts, right?
And this is what the
Democrats will do.
They'll do a commission 'cause
it's not packing the courts,
and the commissioner
will come back,
but this will be my prediction.
The commission will
come back and say,
you cannot be a
judge after the age
of 67 or something, right?
They'll pick an age.
Why will do that?
Because they'll make
automatically all
these people retire
so they could pack the courts.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- And what he's trying
to do, he doesn't-
- They love commissions,
though, don't they?
They love commissions
and hearings.
That must drive you nuts.
Like I say, it's like
a functional person
to be in government.
Another commission,
and another hearing,
and another investigation.
It's like, is anyone
doing work around here,
you know, like actual work?
- You should be, but you
know what else has happened?
This is what people don't grab.
Structure, dictates behavior.
As you look at your Congress,
something has happened
that's never happened before.
No matter what challenge we've
ever had in this country,
you vote by proxy.
You don't have to show up.
So what does it mean
when you vote by proxy?
Well, there are members
of the Democratic Party
that've never come back to
Congress, but they still vote.
Who has their vote?
Pelosi has their vote.
So you're not gonna
vote in committee.
Committee is where
you try to work out,
where you get challenged.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm just gonna bring
the bill to the floor
and I've got all
the votes I need,
so I don't need to
listen to anybody else.
That's why you're getting
this chaotic stuff.
- Do they even have to
give Pelosi an upper down
or if she can basically decide-
- No, no, no.
They give it to her.
- So they have to give it
to her.
But you're saying because
they're not physically there-
- They're not there,
they're not debating.
- Yeah.
- They still get paid.
It's the only place in
America you get paid,
you don't have to
show up to work.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's a great gig.
- My pinned tweet for
almost all of lockdown was,
if you cut politician salaries
until the country opens up,
it would be over in two minutes.
(McCarthy laughs)
Right?
These people got paid while
they shut us all down.
- Through yellow fever,
through the Civil War,
through World War I, through
World War II, we all met,
It would be important if...
Do you think the founders
would really think
if there was a real challenge?
Make sure the people at the
grocery store go to work,
make sure the doctors go to
work, make sure the nurses,
but you elected officials.
No, you go home.
You go protect yourselves.
No, you should lead the nation.
You should be at work.
No, no, They don't do it,
But it empowers her
to be more powerful.
I mean, that's not
good government.
- Didn't we leave the king.
Why are we creating a new one?
- What year were
you first voted in?
- 2006.
- So 2006, so 15 years ago.
Does it see in the
functional sense,
not just sort of optically,
does it seem that much worse
in terms of being able
to do anything right now?
You know what I mean, not
just on the optic side,
but like the real ability,
if you really were trying
to make something happen,
sit down with these guys,
try to do something.
I mean that at the
California level
and at the federal level.
- Yes.
But it's not the
worst it's ever been.
But is it bad? Yes.
And I do believe that's
through leadership, right?
Think about for one moment,
if you sat back and you
read in historical manner
and you said, "Okay, Joe
Biden won the presidency,
but it was a close election."
The Senate ended up 50/50,
and the House was
the smallest margin
that the Democrats
had in 100 years.
Oh, I bet you had to
check and balance.
I bet you had to
find common ground.
No, you would think
it's 2009 again,
that the Democrats have
60 votes in the Senate
and a 40-seat
majority in the house.
They're just ramrodding
things through
and then they're
asking for $6 trillion,
which any economist
will tell you
is the backwards
thing to do today.
- On the money, yeah.
So on the budgets and all
that, when they just, okay,
we're gonna tax these guys,
we're gonna spend this.
When you get these documents,
when they hand it to you,
they show you the big, you know,
we all see the
big thing of paper
and Rand Paul goes
through it on Festivus.
When do you get it?
You get it five minutes
before, usually, right?
But when they show
you these numbers,
in your head, are you like,
what are these
people talking about?
You know what I mean?
What are these numbers?
I think the average
person at this point,
they hear about all
this stuff, 7 trillion,
and everyone's just like,
"It's just made up.
It's monopoly money."
- Because it's true.
I sit in the room
because I'm leader,
and where I have across the
room with Pelosi, with Schumer,
Secretary of Treasury.
And I wanna pull my hair out.
(Rubin chuckles)
There's no basis when you say,
"Oh, it's based on science,
it's based on facts."
No, no, they just pick a number.
I have to have this or
otherwise you can't can do it.
What are you talking about?
It is the most frustrating-
So how do you,
like give me like what a
negotiation is like with that
when they're trying
to pass on you.
Okay, they picked
their crazy number.
What do you do?
'Cause you know that
they're starting number is-
- Let me give you a recent
personal conversation.
So I go to the Oval Office.
First time seeing the
president, it's been 100 days.
So president,
vice-president, four leaders.
President asks, can we do a
bipartisan infrastructure bill?
Okay.
Some other speak.
They go, so the president asks
me, let me ask a question.
So the first question is,
can we do a bipartisan?
Answers yes, we can.
Well, how much money
can you spend on it?
I said, no, Mr. President,
that's the wrong question.
If you're asking my
opinion, you ask can we,
would we work with you
to do a bi-partisan?
The answer is yes.
Now, what I would think
of how to do that,
how do you put the
structure together,
the first thing is we should
both sit down and agree
what is infrastructure?
- Right? (laughs)
Right, that was
the thing online.
How do you define
infrastructure?
- So if it's roads, bridges,
airports, broadband,
yeah, let's decide
what infrastructure is
and then we can see
what is the need.
Then you could decide
what's it cost.
Now, we have these trillions
of dollars over here
that we appropriated
that now you don't need
based upon COVID.
Why spend more money?
Why don't you utilize those?
But if you're asking me what I
think bipartisan would be to,
we would need some NEPA reform,
because some of the biggest
challenges you know,
you'd say build a road,
but it's 10 years later
before it gets built,
even though it's on the
same road you're gonna be.
So let's reform that.
So things happen right away,
because, look, the two
greatest threats to America
are China and the debt.
The debt is gonna
give you fewer options
of what you can
do in the future.
China spends it's time
just studying America,
either stealing from us.
They have a plan for
2049, one world power.
You watch what
President Xi said.
You watch what they have
done with their military.
You watch what they've
done with their islands.
done with Hong Kong.
You watch what they're
saying about Taiwan.
Then we should be focused.
And it shouldn't be a
Republican plan or Democrat.
It should be one American plan.
So if the next century is
gonna be American century,
let's work on it together,
and infrastructure
will be one of them.
But you know what happened?
Even when people came together
and made a bipartisan plan,
the first thing president,
"We have a bipartisan plan."
In the same day said, "But
I still need $6 trillion."
So why would you ever work
in agreement with them again?
- So who's driving
the Biden thing.
I mean, do you really
think he's in charge?
I know you don't want me
to ask you this question,
but do you honestly think
that this guy is in charge?
- Look, when I sat with him,
the president is
there, he's there.
Is he slower and not the person
that I knew as the
vice president?
Yeah.
But I have a real concern
that he's not engaging, right?
I'll give you an example.
You can disagree with Trump.
Within the first three days
he had bipartisan-bicameral,
all sitting at the table.
I watched the
engagement all the time.
And it's not just
who the president is,
the people around have
to be willing to engage.
Speaker Pelosi
normally always wants
a bill just to be one party.
Those are usually the worst
outcomes you could have.
You gotta find common ground
and both people are
gonna have to get,
so it should go
through a committee.
You create a structure to make
that happen and it'll work.
Right now the Democrats
pretty much wanna have it
a one-way street,
and it's the Progressive's
that are driving that.
They would have to say to them,
"No, you're not gonna do it.
I'm gonna make this agreement."
And look if you're president
and I say you just got elected,
you've got this power, but
if you're not gonna use it,
you're gonna lose it.
What are you willing
to fight for?
What are you willing to put
your risk on the line for?
What are you willing
to go out and say?
What are you willing to
tell the American public,
both sides are wrong, this
is where we need to go,
'cause I think in this
country, we might be divided,
but we wanna be United.
- But he's pretty much given
them what they want, right?
- Oh, totally.
- Have you seen him
push back on anything?
- No, he's further
to the left than-
- Well, that's
your Bernie point.
- Yeah, but you know what?
We shouldn't be shocked by that,
'cause you remember
what Barack Obama said
during the campaign?
There is no difference between
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders.
But this is a thing we
should be afraid about.
- He also said that he'd
like to have a third term
where somebody
else is president.
We might have that right now.
What do you think?
- It's got a lot
of people in there.
It's got a lot of influence.
How people handle crisis
tells you a lot, right?
No one's perfect,
everybody's stumbles.
If you write an autobiography,
the times you failed will
be the most interesting
part of the book.
If you quit when you fail,
that's the end of the chapter.
If you pick yourself up,
that's the American story.
That's why we buy
the book, right?
So the president creates
a crisis at the border.
Not because we did anything,
simply because if
a historian wrote,
if Joe Biden became president
and literally did nothing
and kept the policies of
the past administration,
we'd be stronger in
America today, right?
But he made these
executive orders
simply because he wanted to
go the opposite of Trump.
He stopped the wall
from being built
the moment he was
sworn in, right?
So you have these, yeah,
you have a gate in California
because of his executive order
that opened up, the mechanism
broke and they can't fix it,
so they put a truck
there to try to stop it.
It's our cake what
they're doing.
How did he handle it?
He first spent the first month
with Jen as Press Secretary.
It's not a crisis,
it's not a crisis.
We're setting new records.
We're catching people who are
on the terrorist watch list.
We had a 300% increase in drugs
that are coming across that
are killing people, right?
- The kids in cages aren't
kids in cages anymore.
- No they're not anymore, right?
Because we got a
different person.
- Yeah.
- Fentanyl, right?
But you literally caught
people from Yemen,
not on the same day.
Why are they coming?
Who are they talking to?
What do they have planned?
But it's not a crisis.
You set new records
more than 20 years.
And then when it comes a point
that the public understands
it's a crisis, what does he do?
Vice-president's in charge.
So what happens if
China becomes a crisis?
Putin.
I'ma go meet with Putin.
I'm gonna be tough.
I told Putin, I won't stand
with them in a press con,
I gotta go one-on-one.
I gotta do my own.
But I told Putin don't you
come after these, what?
12 or 16 different things,
but you come after
everything else that he does?
Then does he do.
What does he do?
I'm getting tough.
I'm gonna buy an ice cream
and Putin's not gonna do this.
- Yeah.
- He's done nothing.
Anybody who becomes president,
what's the first thing
your adversaries do?
- They test you.
- They test you, yeah.
- And this is my fear.
- Is that 12 list?
He had this list for
people that don't know
what you're talking to.
It was like 12 or 15
things that he said,
"Putin, you can't
do these things."
That almost sounds
like the dumbest,
like that is idiocrasy 101.
These are the things we
don't want you to do.
Everything else
you're good to go,
and actually we know
if you do these things.
It's probably okay too, right?
- What do you
think Putin thinks?
A KGB.
He looks at him and thinks,
"Okay, I don't do those 16,
but I'll do these 1 trillion."
- Right, I'm gonna do a
whole bunch of other stuff.
- I kept my word.
I mean, that's exactly.
Remember, Bush
tells a funny story,
how Putin thinks of everything
in black and white, right?
Like, remember president
Bush of this dog, Barney.
And he takes Putin
to Kennebunkport.
He never took any other
world leader there, right?
And Bush made this statement,
like I looked into
his heart, you know.
Remember, there's
still the union
of collapsed Russias
there, right?
So he's trying to help him.
And Barney's there.
He sees Barney.
So later Bush goes to one
of the summer homes of Putin
and they're having a summit.
Putin says to him, "You
wanna meet my dog?"
Bush loves dogs, "Yeah."
Putin whistles and outcomes
as big hound running,
You know what Putin says,
"Look, bigger, stronger,
faster than Barney."
He thinks in black and white.
So when you told Putin, don't
go these few little things,
he looks, I can do
everything else.
I mean, his one goal in life
is to try to put the Soviet
Union back together again.
Then you got China
and what did they do?
They wanna break
the dollar, right?
So they make an
agreement with Iran.
Biden takes over, he
does military operations.
Then what does Joe
Biden tell Putin?
I'm gonna send warships
to the Middle East,
'cause you just built up
these thousands of people
across Ukraine.
Then Biden backs away
with the warship.
Well, they think that's
your judgment, right?
What did president Trump do
when he was tested
the first time?
- He dropped that crazy bomb.
- Yeah, but how did he
tell President Xi of China?
Here's some chocolate cake.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- In Mar-a-Lago.
"Hey, by the way, there's
53 cruise missiles
heading right now."
Obama puts a red line in Syria,
but he allows him to
cross it 12 times.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- That's the challenge
and the fear that I have.
- All right, so let's do
a little bit more on China
and then I got one
other thing for you.
All right, so on the
China front, I mean,
you know, it's funny because
your demeanor is pretty smiley,
and friendly, and
positive obviously.
- I'm a happy Conservative.
(Rubin laughs)
- Wait, but I thought
Conservatives were
all scary and mean
and normally care war and money.
But you're saying some
pretty scary stuff actually.
Like, it does seem,
I think most people
think at this point
that China is ahead of us.
Like something is wrong here
and China's just watching us
destroy ourselves,
destroy the dollar,
the leadership is
unclear, all that stuff.
Is there a chance that
they're not in charge in 2049?
Do you really see some situation
where the world-
- Yes, there's a chance.
It's not just a chance.
I mean, come on.
- All right happy Conservative.
Bring it.
- Okay.
Every company in China
is a communist company.
They have to.
President Xi is the
head of the party,
but head of the military, puts
himself in the constitution.
That's not an opportunity
to really have
the best form of government.
People crave freedom, right?
32 years ago, a
million people in China
went to Tiananmen Square.
What'd they build?
The goddess of democracy.
What'd it looked like?
Statue of Liberty.
- Statue of Liberty, yeah.
- Where'd they put it?
Directly across from Mao.
What'd China do?
They rolled tanks in.
We all remember that one guy
who stood in front of the tank.
You watch the video, he
stands in front of the tank.
Tank goes right, he moves right.
Tank goes left, he moves, left.
The tank stops, he
jumps on the tank.
Do you know his name?
No.
Nobody knows his name, 'cause
he's probably not alive.
But had that person
been a few years earlier
and he was in the Eastern Bloc
when the Soviet Union collapsed.
It would have been
(indistinct), right?
Those people went
to Tiananmen Square
because they craved
freedom of speech, right?
The thing you have
to understand,
America is more than a country.
We're an idea.
And that idea is more powerful
than anything else around.
Look, there are
points in our history
where other people
were stronger.
When I was in graduate
school in MBA,
we'd do SWOT analysis.
Strength, weaknesses,
opportunities, and threats.
Let's start with our strength.
Who's the largest
economy in the world?
We are,
what's the dominant currency?
The dollar.
Who has the greatest
military at any given time
on the face of the earth?
We do.
Do we draft people?
No.
No, they volunteer to
risk their own lives
for you and I, right?
When you go around
the Horn of Africa
and the pirates come in
and take you hostage,
who comes to save you?
The Navy Seals, right?
When you have a challenge,
how many countries
have aircraft carriers?
No other country has more
than two but us, right?
But they're building,
they're trying to gain us.
If you live in another
nation and you're sick,
where do you wanna go
for your healthcare?
America.
If you live in another
country, you live in China
and you have wealth, where
do you send your children
to go to school?
America. Okay?
So where are people breaking
the law to get into America?
- Nobody's leaving.
Nobody's leaving.
Okay?
- Yeah.
- So we start with a great
deal amount of strength,
but we also have a system
that allows disrupters to come
so we improve constantly.
In China, they have a
small group that decides.
They take you off an app.
You get too big for
them, they collapse.
The greatest death
rate of any billionaire
is in China, right?
'Cause they don't-
- Oh, they go missing.
They go missing, yeah.
- But this is our challenge.
China has spent their
time studying America
in every aspect,
from stealing from us, from
the growth of food and others,
but they also watched
how we fought war, okay?
They watched Desert Storm.
They watched it.
America could move
an aircraft carrier
250 miles away from anybody
and come in bomb you, right?
So what they spend
their time on?
Building aircraft carriers now,
but they spent their time
on building a missile
to sink an aircraft carrier.
They watch our men and women.
The troops don't fight
by just getting on land,
they fight by space.
So we spend a lot
of time in space.
Do you know the other day
China sent three
astronauts to space.
Did they go to the
International Space Station?
They went to the
Chinese Space Station.
They don't play with
the rest of the world.
Do you know China's
landed on the moon?
On the backside of the moon,
the dark side of the moon..
It's hard to land there.
We haven't landed there.
China realizes our aircraft
carriers, so what did they do?
They built the islands.
What'd they do when Barack
Obama asked them about them.
"We won't weaponize them."
Xi said that.
But what did he do?
He weaponized them to
push us further away.
The only time our aircraft
carriers in recent history
were not in the Strait
there was during COVID.
Now, can we win?
- (chuckles) I was
gonna say, you know,
the question is about-
- The answer is yes.
- Yeah.
Is there a window
on opportunity?
Just like you started
with Kent, California,
can we win here?
I just created eight pillars
to China based upon COVID.
If there's any moment in time
to wake up, to study, right?
For the rest of
the world to unite.
Once China found they had
COVID, what'd they do?
They stopped flights.
Not international
flights, domestic flights.
Then they dominated the
World Health Organization
to lie to the rest of the world.
They hoarded PPE.
Then as it went forward and
the rest of the world had it,
what'd did they do?
Well, they controlled so much
mechanism, what they built.
When France needed PPE, even
though they sent free to China,
China says, "We'll
sell you some,
but you have to have
Walway with you."
They utilized COVID
to get more gain
within their own technology
around the world.
When Australia said
they wanted to study
where COVID came from, they
went and put sanctions,
tried to hurt them economically.
They said the first place
their nuclear weapon could hit
would be Australia.
They try to intimidate
what you would do.
So what America should
do is actually lead.
We come from strength.
We should declassify
the information
for the entire world to know
why did 3 million people
in the world die, and
did they need to die?
Why did 600,000 Americans die?
Why did they?
Why did we have to in
the process of COVID?
The next thing I would do is end
any gain of function research.
And end it from this aspect,
don't give a grant
to somebody else
because you're
going around saying,
my government's not
giving to China,
but I give to you 'cause
you give to China, right?
- Can you just explain
what that is very quickly.
- Gain of function is what
you're taking from a mechanism
that this didn't come from,
oh, somebody ate a bat, right?
They were trying to
mechanize it and change it
and they were studying
it in the process.
- So meaning us, human.
Scientists are doing this.
This isn't that a bat
and a monkey did it,
and here we are, yeah.
- And do we put funding into it?
Well, apparently for a long
time we said we didn't,
but we're finding out
now we probably did.
Make sure the NIH, which I
love, doesn't provide grants
that go to North Korea, Iran.
Why do we help fund
our enemies, okay?
Then why don't we do this?
Why don't we start looking at
who we're providing
our visas to?
How many times have we found
somebody from China's over here
on a visa, but actually
belongs to their military?
How many times do we
catch them on a plane
that they are
stealing documents?
How many times have we found out
that they're funding the
professor at the university?
- Didn't Swalwell sleep with
a Chinese spy or something?
I mean.
- Yes. Why?
Okay, that's a good question.
I wanna finish my eight pillars.
- Yeah, yeah. Sorry.
- But let's talk about this.
For the rest of the world.
- Yeah.
- When you get to Congress,
Republicans and Democrats
decide what committees you get,
but there are a
couple of committees
that are totally different.
They're decided by groups
and they're voted on, right?
Intel committee is different
than any other committee,
'cause members
who serve on Intel
can only serve for a
certain amount of time,
but they find out information
all the other members
can't have, okay?
They're only selected
by their leaders.
I select all the Republicans,
Pelosi select all
their Democrats.
I am part of what is called
the Gang of Eight, right?
The leaders and the
leaders in Intel.
We're provided information
than other people are, right?
To know what's going on.
So I can't talk to you
about things I know,
but on the Intel committee,
this is all public domain,
we could talk about.
What we know publicly, a
Chinese spy, and also remember,
Senator Feinstein,
we found out later,
the driver of more than
10 years was a Chinese spy
in Silicon valley.
There've been in pictures
together, they used to be.
This woman, a Chinese spy,
creates a relationship
with Swalwell
when he's in the city council.
He runs for Congress.
She helps.
She puts interns in his office.
Do you know how difficult it is
to get on the Intel Committee?
When Swalwell was put
on the Intel Committee,
they were in the minority,
so they had fewer seats.
He was a sophomore getting
put on the Intel Committee.
Every single member asked
me for the Intel Committee.
There's very few
openings, right?
There's people highly qualified,
there's just not
openings for them.
Gets put on.
It's not...
Then the public says that
the FBI came to warn, right?
They warned the leaders,
they had a briefing.
He's kept on the Intel.
This woman just-
- They were warning them
that there was a spy
basically, right?
Yeah.
- I wonder how they knew
she was a spy, right?
She wasn't just spy and then
you had a mayor in other parts.
Think about how big your
spy mechanism must be
if you have enough
money to have a spy
that cares about you when
you're in the city council.
Our talks about you
getting to Congress.
- There's some real planning
and volunteering.
- You put a long
Manchurian candidate.
Remember, Swalwell
ran for president.
The only thing he has left
is a bunch of shoelaces or
something, I don't know.
He spent the most money on that.
But anyways, now you know this.
You put him on.
You did not know.
Now you know as a leader.
Okay, if Swalwell was
in the private sector,
he could not get a
security clearance
because he had a
relationship with a spy.
But only in America can he
be given the Intel Committee
where he knows all the secrets,
but there's 200 other Democrats
who are qualified
to be on that slot
and she keeps appointing.
I become leader.
- Wait, sorry, but is that also
because they know damn well
that the media is never
gonna call them out on it.
Instead it's oh, Trump Jr.
had lunch with somebody
seven years ago
on the (indistinct) side.
- Can you believe that?
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But that's part of it, right?
That they can keep
doing this nonsense.
Well, I guess we're
allowed to talk about that
on YouTube now.
- But (chuckles).
- You probably-
- This probably
never gonna show.
This will never show.
- Your probably...
Don't worry I got locals.com
and it can all go there.
- Okay, but I become leader.
I've never heard
about this, right?
Because the FBI comes
and just provides it
to a select few people on Intel.
So I asked for a briefing.
Speaker Pelosi comes and
has this briefing with me.
What I know with
what the FBI told me,
he should never be on Intel
and Pelosi reappointed
him in Intel.
I don't understand this.
Have you said this to her.
- Yes.
- What did she say?
- But this is worse.
I brought a motion to the
floor to remove him from Intel,
put another Democrat on.
The Democrats, all defendant.
They don't even have the
briefing from the FBI,
but they defended having him on.
And think about this,
he cannot get a security
clearance in the private sector,
but they voted to let him
have the security clearance
of American secrets.
- Okay, so when you
say that to Nancy,
when you say, "Nancy,
we got a problem here.
There's a spy, et
cetera, et cetera.
Nancy, just me and you
in the room right now,"
what does she say?
- She handles her own members.
But you know what they did to?
They went and removed
Marjorie Greene
for something
Marjorie Greene said
before she was ever
a member of Congress.
- Right, as if they don't
make Nazi references
every two seconds
these people, yeah.
- It's crazy.
- All right, so let's get to
the rest of those pillars.
And then I'll let you get to
the business of government.
- Okay, so the other thing we
should look at is after 9/11,
we changed the sovereign
laws that American,
if they got killed, they
could sue Saudi Arabia, right?
You got to court,
your day in court.
Why wouldn't we do that to
allow the 600,000 who have died,
their family, to Sue China,
to be able to get
accountability?
Do you know where the
next winter Olympics
is gonna be held?
- It's China? Right?
2028.
- Why would the world...
No, it's-
- They're 2024.
- Yeah, it's coming up quick.
- Yeah.
- Why would...
Is it 22?
- I think it's 22 or 24, yeah.
Why would the
world reward China?
Why wouldn't we
move the Olympics?
Why?
And, I mean, why wouldn't
we hold them accountable?
Why after COVID goes through
kills more than
3 million people,
why does China get stronger
and the rest of the world
have to be weaker?
Why wouldn't we unite?
Why wouldn't this
be the opening?
be the wake up call?
Why wouldn't the rest of the
country sit back and say,
"Whoa, I see what's
gonna happen."
So when you promised it...
the first time I ever
went to China was in 1995
and there was a sign
in Tiananmen Square.
It was the number of days
and number of minutes
till Hong Kong came
under control, okay?
It was like a year away.
And when Hong Kong
switched, when the UK,
they signed a
document for 50 years.
What'd they do when COVID
hit, they took it over.
"The Apple Daily" there,
the newspaper for 26 years,
now shut down.
Yeah.
You get less freedom.
Tiananmen Square, roll
cameras, less freedom.
In China if someone
steals your purse,
you'll find it in a minute.
Not because they're
good at detective work,
is because they have
a camera on everyone.
In China if you're Chinese
and you wanna buy
an airline ticket,
if you have enough money,
there's no guarantee you
get the airline ticket.
You know what guarantees
whether you can buy
the airline ticket?
Your score,
everybody has scores.
- [Rubin] Social credit.
- Yes.
Why is it that Google
would work with China,
but not work with
American military?
Why is it that Nike considers
themselves a Chinese company?
Why does the NBA bend the knee?
So the question is, can
we win the next century?
Yes.
But will we?
Will we have the will?
Okay, when I watched
what happened with COVID,
it made me start
thinking, you know what?
We all thought the world
put China and the WTO,
the World Trade Organization,
they'll become more democratic.
No, they haven't, but
they took every advantage.
Why do they get special funding
as a developing nation today?
I mean, it's crazy.
Why do they get this benefit?
Why would we allow this?
They're competing
with us everywhere.
They just put a
military base in Africa.
They wanna find one
in the Atlantic.
This road belt system.
They are like loan sharks,
where they take these countries
and they give them billions
of dollars they can't afford.
They say, "We'll build
the infrastructure."
But they lie to them and
they don't create any jobs,
'cause they bring the
Chinese to build it
then they say,
you didn't pay it.
I need to take it over.
I need to put the military here
to protect my infrastructure.
I mean, they have a plan.
You can read it.
- So I'm not sure where
your silver lining is.
It doesn't seem to me that-
- The silver lining is
structure dictates behavior.
Freedom will always
win out over communism,
over dictatorship.
- So you're giving me
the long game here,
which is just that the idea
of freedom is stronger than-
- This is different than
the Soviet Union, right?
The Soviet Union,
we outspent them.
We can't outspend China, right?
But what should we do?
For the same reasons we started
the three communicades
with China
to do something about
the Soviet union,
why aren't we working a better
relationship with India?
They have a bigger population.
They care about America.
They love America.
They love the idea of freedom.
Modi, what he's doing to
build his nation, right?
Why don't we start standing up
for freedom around the world?
If we take the American belief,
and we say when China tells
us that you're gonna make
a new "Top Gun" again,
but you can't have
Taiwan on the back.
When you have John
Cena in Mandarin
that he's sorry 'cause
Taiwan's a country,
that's when you're in trouble.
But look at this, okay,
after COVID we should
really start and think
our critical minerals
or others, right?
Do we make medicine
in America anymore?
We're too tied to China?
The supply chain of
what we developed.
And we should think of a
supply chain totally different.
We should think of the
supply chain in America.
When we started having problems
with ventilators and others,
what'd we do?
We went to our warehouses
where government bought
these ventilators.
They sat there and when you
needed them 25 years later,
they weren't ready.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- So this is what we should
do, modernize, right?
We should go to companies
'cause a free market works.
3M builds masks, right?
Let's say 3M you build a
million masks a year, okay?
What the American
government's gonna do,
is you're gonna
build 1.1 million.
We're gonna buy 100,000.
You're gonna store them.
You know what you're
gonna do the next year?
You're gonna put that and
you're gonna sell that 100,000
and you're gonna make
a new one, right?
And we're gonna go
to all of our allies
and we're gonna tell them,
you can join in this too, right?
So now you're gonna have scale.
So we're not gonna have
to offshore our business
over to China, we're gonna
make them in America.
We're gonna find
critical minerals
that we're not
gonna let them dump
so our businesses can't survive.
So if they're tied, if we
wanna build an electric car,
but they control the minerals,
how are we gonna do it?
If we need to make a new weapon
but they control the minerals,
we could get into
conflict, but in 60 days,
are we gonna be in trouble
'cause we can't supply
ourselves again.
It is a wake-up call
for us that we rethink.
It's the same point
of maybe that we were
before World War II and
others that we got complacent.
That we didn't think long-term,
we thought the world
was harmony, right?
We should use the strength
position we're in today
for the idea of freedom.
America has never gone to
conquer another country
for the sake of controlling it.
We've only gone engagement
for freedom, right?
That's different than any
other country around us.
There's other people
around the world
that crave that same thing,
that understand that
we're more than a country,
that we're an idea.
- So I think if I
can sum that up,
you're hopeful because
our ideas are right,
their ideas are wrong but-
- Our structure is right.
- But yeah, our structure
is right.
- Our division is hurting us.
- Yeah.
- They're getting a benefit
over our division and
we should wake up.
I'll tell you another story.
You know I have
a lot of stories.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Okay, so we went
to the 75th
anniversary of D-Day.
Very moving.
Then we did a codel.
And when I sat and
walked those fields
and you look in France,
and you look at those headstones
from a Star of David to a cross,
but you look at the age,
you look at the names.
They must've just got into
and killed on that day, right?
And you've paused for
a moment to think,
what could we have done
before to not let that happen?
Let's learn from our mistakes
and not get to the
point of there.
Well, the challenge of what
we watch with China doing,
and others, why don't we
have one policy about this?
So I went to the
Democrats and I said,
let's create a committee
or a task force,
equal number of Republicans,
equal number of Democrats.
It took me eight months,
And you know what?
They finally said yes.
And then we narrowed it down
to how many people
could be on it.
And we looked at
every aspect, right?
So we have a plan.
China has a plan, so why
don't we have a plan?
How do we make America,
you know, from education,
from economics, from everything?
We even brought the
Washington Post reporter in
and he interviewed,
'cause we're gonna have
that article written as
soon as we announce it.
The day before, you know
what the Democrats did?
They backed away.
They never gave me a reason,
but part of the reason
I believe they thought,
'cause COVID had hit,
that it'd given
advantage to Trump
that we were doing something.
That they put politics
before country.
Now, the one thing
I will tell you,
if we are successful
enough to have the majority
and I have the privilege
of being speaker,
I'll create that.
I moved forward and
created a China task force,
and 2/3 of every bill
that we brought out
was bi-partisan.
We need to plan for
the next century.
- So that gets me to
the last question,
which is, is that, so you
wanna be majority leader?
I mean, I think that's the plan.
- Not the majority
leader, the speaker.
- Sorry, the majority,
right, right.
The speaker. Right, right.
- That's the Senate.
- Sorry.
You wanna be the
speaker, obviously,
meaning you want to have
the majority in Congress.
- Look, to be honest, my
goal is not to be speaker.
- Yeah.
- My goal is to make the next
century, the American century.
To do that, I believe
Republicans need to
take the majority.
I wanna do everything in my
power to make that happen.
If I becomes speaker,
then that's good,
but I don't have to
be from that aspect.
- Yeah, but to get to
where you kinda think
America's gotta go,
that would be a nice
little plan for you.
And then-
- Look at what's happening
in the streets.
Defunding of the police.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- Look, what's happening,
economic inflation.
We haven't seen these type
of problems since the '70s.
Since the last time the
Democrats had major control.
- So I guess then, well, I guess
a good bonus last question,
which is, this
interview strikes me
as very hopeful actually.
And we're not
getting a lot of, no.
Well, I always tell people
I'm a world weary optimist.
I'm an optimist because I
don't think I could do this.
So probably similar to you.
I don't think I could do what
I do if I wasn't an optimist,
'cause I have to believe
that we can make
things better, right?
But I'm also a realist.
So the world's tough..
- Let me sum up that question.
- Yeah. Bring us home.
- With why you need
to come to my office.
- Yes.
- In my conference
room, (claps), I have
the last painting.
(inhales sharply)
It's Washington
crossing the Delaware.
It's eight feet by 16 feet.
You know the painting, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
I know the painting, yeah.
You know when that took place?
Christmas, 1776, right?
You know, when it was painted?
1850/1851.
It wasn't painted.
- Wow, 75 years later.
- It wasn't painted by
somebody who was there.
There was no iPhone
to take a picture,
and he wasn't even in America.
He was a German immigrant
who lived in America.
You know why he painted it?
'Cause he went back to Germany
and he wanted Germany
to have a revolution
based upon the ideas of America.
Now, his talent was art.
So he paints this painting
and it gets it historically
incorrect, okay?
If you look at the Delaware,
it looks like the Rhine,
but he's German, right?
He puts Washington in a
rowboat with 13 people.
13 colonies, right?
But Washington
historians will tell you
crossed in a Durham boat.
He has Washington standing
up in the middle of winter,
in a ceremonial uniform
with his hand on his chest.
You look at Washington and say,
My God, I bet that man
has never lost a battle.
But history tells us that
that moment he had never won.
He'd only lost, okay?
'Cause that was
our first victory
When we surprise the Hessians.
Now, when you look
at this painting,
don't look at Washington,
look at who's in the boat.
The second person, he's
wearing a beret, he's Scottish.
The person directly across
from him in the green jacket
rowing in a cadence
with him is black.
You come down in the
middle of the boat,
the person who looked
like the strongest one
and the hardest in
the red is a woman.
And in the very back
is a native American.
Now the second to last
person is a farmer.
And if you look at the farmer,
there's a hand across his face.
It's the hand of the
13th person nobody sees.
You see what Emmanuel was
saying, this young artist,
here we are not a
country, but an idea,
having lost every battle, but
willing to risk everything
for the idea of freedom on
what most people would say
is our holiest of night.
Here's a hand, will
you get it and join us?
That's as true today
as it was then.
The water may still be rough,
what we have in front of us
may be different challenges
than we've seen before,
but if we're all on
the boat together,
rowing together from every
walk of life, we will win,
because we are an
exceptional country.
- Here's a hand.
Let's build together.
- Join us.
- Thank you.
- All right.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.